Sudan's military rulers and a civilian coalition
have agreed in principle to establish a joint
transitional council.
But the makeup of the council is still undecided.
Thousands of protesters calling for civilian
rule are continuing their weeks-long demonstration
in the capital Khartoum.
DW's Melanie Cura Daball is there.
They call it a sit-in, but here in the streets
of Khartoum nothing is still.
Walking among the protestors in the capital
you’re surrounded by transfixing scenes
Speeches and poetry on provisional stages,
the echo of revolutionary songs in the air,
Sudanese flags fluttering everywhere
Jubilation across the generations is the overwhelming
sound you hear all over town - nevertheless,
people here in Sudan keep on insisting their
fight isn’t over just yet.
A lot of the peoples demands have not been
yet.
That’s why we still come here.
I have come all the way from El-Gadarif and
I’m going to remain here until the regime
actually falls.
Everybody here is united.
The people give you a sense of comfort.
When you are sitting here there is no fear.
These people will only be satisfied when “the
regime steps down completely and power is
handed to a civilian transitional government”.
It’s an incredibly well organized and cheerful
protest we are witnessing here: with volunteers
doing security checks, revolutionary art being
created on the streets, and cleaning patrols
taking care of the rubbish.
You can tell, these protestors are here to
stay and make sure that their revolution isn’t
stolen from them.